he said he'll check how our Yeti okay
rich could be what good to have you back
what do you think about tonight's game
on the I said we have for me right here
I got a feeling that we're gonna see a
lot of pucks being pulled out by
goaltender's in this game out of the
back of the net I really do rich I think
that you know Vegas hasn't had much luck
here the last couple of games I think
they've had like a total of five posts
they had the wide open net in Game four
early in period one for James Neal and
he hits the post and the other guy I
mean they played a good first period and
all the things look up at the board and
there's a crooked number up there and
got a half a snowman it's three nothing
after the first period so you know to me
I just think that this is one of those
games where Vegas is gonna come out
you're gonna play with that speed
they're gonna generate the chance the
crowds going to be up for grabs it's
going to be a gonna be a gong show and I
just I feel like it's going to be a lot
like Game one I think there's gonna be a
lot of pucks put up on the board and you
know Washington can play that way but
Washington has proven that's not the way
that they win they want to close
checking they want to dictate the terms
and surveying if they want to go ahead
and and so call play with house money
get up a couple of goals and fourth
Washington to open up and try to get an
attract me type of game if you're Vegas
so I want to just reiterate when you say
gong sure you're talking about the game
not the pregame ceremony right Eddie
well you know what I was a fan of the
gong show when I was growing up we
cheered watching on TV so I'm talking
that you know in the most flattering way
I mean it's just an incredible it's an
incredible experience Vegas has done an
incredible job this organization and the
fan bases they bought in right rich we
talked about it last week like this is
their own this isn't a team coming from
City a B or C like this is Vegas is own
Vegas born and this city is really
excited and yeah they know the Tufts
gonna be in the building but you know
they're they're very confident group and
they're just looking to have to say
let's just win one game let's just win
the first period and go from there heavy
Eddie Olczyk of NBC Sports joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show did you guys
in the and the broadcast crew discuss
the two signs that were placed in
windows
in DC area sporting goods stores Eddie
have you discussed that at all okay I
love a boy I've been breaking news for
like over the bias show yes a to DC area
sporting goods stores have placed signs
in the window selling gear they're
selling championship you're not selling
it yet they're letting you know that get
in after the wind says one show one sign
at six location is letting you know
where championship merchandise will will
be available well it doesn't say it
doesn't say it doesn't say it's
Washington capital championship tag hash
tag all casts on all signs okay well you
know that that's a couple of companies
that are pretty confident I would guess
I mean that's really what that sounds
like
I mean were you superstitious when you
play well I wouldn't really use
I really wouldn't use that word I would
probably use more of a routine there's
probably the word that I like so yeah it
was very
that's not superstitious to me and that
sounded like you didn't want it you know
you wanted all your ducks in a certain
row and you wouldn't want to deviate
from that plan
yeah creature of habit for sure if it
works
I drove the same way to the rink I put
on my equipment the same way I take my
sick the same way I only talk to certain
people so yes absolutely whatever is
working I don't care what it is I look
at for me as a handicapper for horse
racing you know obviously now for
broadcasting is a different story but it
all look if it's working if that if that
blue pen is working I'm grabbing that
thing and it's coming with me everywhere
I go until it either runs out of ink or
I couldn't take a one horse race so then
I guess since we're routine II and not
superstitious who do you think if things
do wrap up tonight would deserve the
Conn Smythe well I think it's one one a
with Kuznets off and all that skin to
the Capitol's I really do rich you know
he has been just absolutely incredible
including that sauce been there every
step of the way like it's because that's
what happens to have a five-point game
tonight it'd be hard to not look at him
and give it to him
you know look the gray date has been
just that so to me I wouldn't be stocked
if it's either one of those guys I don't
see a no braid and hope he's played
really well but I would look at those
two guys one in one a you know probably
Ovechkin would get it if things you know
Kuznetsov doesn't have a big game
tonight I think just just because and I
don't have an issue with it but
Kuznetsov deserves every bit of the
accolades that any other player would
get for the capital because he's just
been flat-out awesome that said wouldn't
you say though this series turned on the
the save the save where where the the
paddle is what hope Ebert right in front
of an open net that that's that's what
obviously that would have just tied the
game yeah and like the ascent game to
into overtime but you really just never
know
right Eddie no no no I mean look if you
don't have goaltender winning the
National Hockey League especially come
playoff time and yeah that was an
incredible athletic ability a little bit
of luck involved as well now let's talk
to player on the Vegas mall tonight said
you know shot that [ __ ] shot it back in
the brain and hoping instead of
elevating it or shooting on the short
side but yeah and then look at you you
will look at Turning Point you will look
at the finding moments but I look at
this series back in Game one rich were
Washington had a lead for three in the
third period John Carlson hits the post
and then Ryan riess cross-checks John
Carlson in front of the net tied the
game up at four should have been no goal
should've been a penalty on the play but
miss call Vegas takes advantage and then
at the end of the game five for Lars
Eller midsole misses a wide open at the
tide again so like it goes in streaks
and right now I think Washington has
realized is that if they're gonna win
and how they've won is they're gonna win
by checking they're gonna win by how
they play without the puck because they
know they can put the puck in the back
of the net but for me you know this
series this series changed is when
Washington realize how they have to play
and why they've had so much success in
these playoffs so far a couple more
minutes left with any old check of NBC
Sports you're sitting next to an
all-time great heady obviously the
players aren't some of the only all-time
greats that are associated with this
doc Emmerich what in the world is it
like sitting next to an all-world
broadcaster watching him perform his
craft at such a high level Eddie it's an
intimidating period of Siddim there's no
there's no question about that and you
got to be on your toes
and you got to listen because doc drops
in some of the greatest one-liners and
some of the greatest stories while play
is going on and you know I just remember
a game and it would be trite in the
playoffs a couple of years ago or I
think he was talking about you know
Jimmy Howard of the Detroit Red Wings
the goaltender and you know he's talking
about an incredible save in his cold and
savage there's two points for all over
the course of the last six playoff games
and you know and the record of the
Detroit Red Wings I don't by the way he
got his first set of hockey equipment at
the hardware store that his dad owned or
you know he got the groceries in the
hardwoods hardware store and he got his
hockey equipment from there and what a
safe I our dad you know he just has that
incredible ability to be able to get in
and out with a story and never break
stride and I can't express how lucky I
am and honored I am to be able to sit
next to a guy like doc day in and day
out and the stories he's able to tell
away from the ring I mean to me that's
working next time when the booth is
flat-out awesome but getting a chance to
be with doc away from the rink and have
dinner with them and travel with them
and just chat with them this he's a
great friend I know he has my back as I
hope he knows that I have is and just
I'm thrilled to be able to work with him
on a nightly basis well you guys do such
a great job
obviously with Pierre down on the ice
and then the pictures that come home
it's it's really great man and and
tonight could be a memorable one for
Washington fence they will never forget
this moment and they'll never forget the
moment where they know where to get
theirs their championship hats what a
place what a place to be able to
celebrate you if you happen when the
family kept in Las Vegas I mean like
that could be that's epic right that
couldn't I mean nobody sleeps there
anyways the golf room you can go from
hotel to nightclub to wherever you want
here and and never stop so we'll see if
they can get it done
I believe that they can but it'll be
really tough for Vegas those get uh you
know those get a lead because that's
that's their bread and butter to be able
to like the
lead and and enforce seems to kind of
play outside their comfort zone but
Washington again has done a really good
job of being able to keep them intact
for the most part and they've gone a
little dry offensively that mean Vegas
so we'll see what happens but I think
they get off to a really good start
tonight and as I said earlier I just got
a feeling I've sharpened up my pencils
and uh nice I think we're gonna have to
be putting a few nuts few names down the
net scorecard this so last one for you
Eddie if this does close out tonight do
you do you go to the Belmont will you be
part of the brawl I'm going to the
Belmont oh I'm going out I will be there
I will be there at some point I got a
couple of different plans riches you
know in this industry you got to fly by
the seat of your pants every once in a
while so if the game ends in regulation
in Vegas wins I'll be able to catch the
red-eye tonight to New York and then get
ready for work tomorrow and if not and
I'll fly tomorrow and get ready for the
bell my dad are they so can't wait to I
can't wait to get get to New York after
game five any do you think we see
history yes yes I do
you did not say here's the best horse he
is the best horse the mile and a half
race rich will become a half mile run
the first mile is just the position and
you know gallop along and I think
justify is now they just think he's the
best horse and I think we'll see that on
Saturday and I'm also going to look at a
horse by the name of Oscar the number 4
horse trained by Bill Mott so I'm
looking at one four and all different
combinations but I think we do see her
second Triple Crown winner in four years
well just because you know the name of
the the name of this program is has the
word show in it just for those who are
interested in in showing after you
mentioned a place na na win Eddie do you
have any idea what you'd like to show on
Saturday just for you no you know what
giggles ready yeah probably say probably
say the ten horse blended citizens how's
that okay
well cuz you're one let your blended
citizen as well Eddie one for ten eight
Eddie and it always love our chats
appreciate it enjoy safe travels we'll
chat soon okay said he'll check the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience
you